SPEAKER: This game is completely
different from The Blacks.
The challenge here isn't
explaining what the game is.
The challenge
is innovating a medium
that goes beyond a game.
♪ (ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
I'm trying to learn
how to attune to my needs.
Even though I think
I'm only, like,
29 percent serious about that.
I don't really know
what "attune" means yet.
SPEAKER:
Clearly, this particular ritual
isn't working for you.
I do love you.
We're not on that anymore.
We've taken this spiritual shit
too far!
SPEAKER 2:
The whole point of the app
is we get our shit back.
SPEAKER 3:
So, where the cash at now?
SPEAKER 4:
It's actually all land.
In this moment, which, for you,
is the real you?
SPEAKER 2: Which are you?
Pirate or king?
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪